take a look at spencer turnbull tonight
obviously the no no he's got to be
feeling good record at three and two 31
strikeouts eight walks to whip below one
that no no's got to feel good man aboard
for ahmed rosario the one-owner rosario
crown ball to third base scooped up by
candelario down to the second one
relayed over first castro to scope 543
double play
ramirez pops it up left side candelario
gives chase now settles in and that's an
eight pitch first inning for spencer
turnbull nice way to start the week
right it'll be sam hench's on the mound
for the indians he's coming off a rough
start where he went just an inning and
two-thirds gave up five hits and six
runs the set the look at second the
pitch
and there's a line drive and he'll get
the out one away yeah tried going the
other way hit a line drive right into
the tracks of hernandez but good base
running they got back in time they took
that first step and that's the first
thing you know when you're a base runner
out there line drive you freeze so you
don't get doubled off and they were able
to get back on time so he gets the first
out
the veteran miguel cabrera
swing and a miss he struck him off two
down so sam hanches gets his first kick
and there are two down for eric yes
that's good that that's just good
because he got him to swing on that and
those are borderline pitches and he
continued to swing at him so he got
himself out in that at bat well eric has
been a breath of fresh air for detroit
he's got a six-game hitting streak
a swing and a miss struck him out with a
slider oh what a shot in the arm for sam
hentges
it looked like disaster in the making
with back-to-back walks to start the
ending and then he ends it by striking
out cabrera and haas tigers need to take
advantage of this wildness three walks
so far he stranded two in the first
inning willie castro betting
castro sprays one down the right field
line and that's a fair ball goodreads
will score easily
reyes is being held up at third willie
castro's got himself an rbi double well
just uh off the fisted out there nicely
niko's on second base he's gonna score
easily victor's behind he gets a pretty
good read i tell you victor wanted to
score right here you're going to see
chip hill right now at the bottom there
he's in the stop only one out right you
get your lead off man on that's a great
sign for willy castro here's robbie
grossman
a drive to center harold ramirez has it
victor reyes will tag he will score
easily and moving up to third base is
willie castro that's dynamite base
running on the part of the tigers
two-nothing detroit
this is again excellent pressure take
what they give you
brush them make it more passive play you
know you see one out go back to second
he must score both advance he hustles
all the way you know sometimes you
assume that he's not going to throw it
to third and you get yourself out but uh
robbie grossman that's just good
baseball huh owen miller leading off the
third inning for cleveland tribe down
two yesterday made his major league
debut and it's swung on a little topper
over the mound by second good from
gloves throws down in time
the first major league hit for owen
miller is an infield single on a chopper
over the mound goodrem did everything he
could at short but owen miller gets that
first major league hit
and what did he do he put the ball in
play he didn't strike out and that's
what the indians love about owen miller
and folks you'll have a lot more major
league hits before it's all said and
done that'll bring up jake bowers
a swing and a liner towards second by
the diving castro into right field a
base hit castro may have just got a
piece of leather on it as he dove
towards second and couldn't make the
great catch
so miller to second bowers is at first
and the indians
maybe can
return the favor now the indian seventh
and eighth hitters get base hits and
here's catcher renee rivera
he got one to hit
in the center field and it will drop and
it gets by
on his way to third owen miller they're
going to wave him home and he will score
it into third base safely goes jake
bowers it's an rbi single for renee
rivera and the indians come right back
with three hits to open the third inning
well we told you it's a deep center
field so normally the outfielders are
going to play deeper than they normally
do this is where you get burned in a
field like this tying run 90 feet away
and cesar hernandez coming up
swung on rolled towards second castro
the second one good rooms relay not in
time game tied bauer scores on the
fielder's choice boy that looked taylor
made to be a 4-6-3 double play but good
hustle by cesar hernandez gets his 14th
rbi
no mar
opportunity
still in the search of his first hit off
a lefty this year mazara grounds one
by the first baseman and into right
field that's an rbi single for nomar
mazzara and the tigers have reclaimed
the lead
and that'll bring up victor reyes down
in the dirt nice sliding stop by revere
throw to second and they've got him hung
up between first and second hernandez
runs mazar to first bowers now throws to
the plate trying to score and tagged out
at the plato's good room heads up play
by the indians as mazara broke for
second then got into the rundown
the throw went to bowers at first but he
didn't worry about tagging out mazara
because he saw goodram coming home and
he made a perfect throw to the plate to
get nico goodram it's 3-2 so ramirez
back into the count
weinbrecht up the middle off his glove
harold will beat it out and we got a tie
ball game i don't know how turbo got his
glove up in time but thank goodness he
did yeah he was very lucky there two
balls two strikes two out spaces loaded
tribe and tigers tied at three in the
seventh inning and the dirk got away
from haas here comes miller throw to the
plate miller's in safely with a head
first slide and the indians take the
lead on the aggressive base running of
owen miller 4-3 lead on the wild pitch
daniel norrish coming on now to face
eddie rosario base is still loaded
line
into left center field of base hit
that's gonna score two
and the indians have taken a commanding
three-run lead here in the seventh
inning willie's overdue to drive the
ball hard somewhere tigers trying to get
something started every lead all single
three and two now they count on willie
castro
fly ball deep right field naylor over
and that ball's gone
willie
sir
willie castro with a two-run shot tigers
close to within one
six five indians lead now here in the
seven well you talk about you talk about
going down and put a severe buggy whip
on it he just did now you get nico
goodra
and he fists one in the air to shallow
left near the line on the run making the
catch in foul gown rosario oh what a
play by eddie rosario charging hard in
the foul ground down the left field line
and made the running catch kind of in
the heel of the glove and the tigers
down to their last out clause a you've
got a keel badou
line to right
what a catch
luplow saves the day
and the indians hang on for a one-run
victory